okay so in the world there are things
that you think will just go away but
apparently they just never do these
include but are not limited to war in
the Middle East that rash that you got
from that girl who insisted that you
were her first time and freak ass oil
spills in the Gulf of Mexico so as the
world has already heard there are
500,000 to 800,000 gallons of oil being
pumped into the Gulf of Mexico every day
kind of old news at this point and at
first the word was people please just
calm down and just take a breath I know
this whole oil spill business has some
people a little worried I mean trust me
I would be too you know what I mean
and it's the ecosystem in a little bit
of danger but I promise you it's not a
danger that can't be avoided and trust
me measures are being taken and it is
all under control now trust me relax
take a breath one month later and some
people have even theorized that this was
a terrorist attack and the FBI is
narrowed it down to three suspects it
was totally that third guy and now
everyone is just out of ideas I know
this because I logged onto YouTube one
day and there was a banner on the top of
the screen that said something like Gulf
of Mexico oil spill how would you fix it
and then people could comment their
harebrained ideas as to how they would
fix the problem that was when I knew
that the brains behind the whole oil
spill recovery project were just out of
ideas that was when I knew we were all
[ __ ]
and then we see stories in the news that
are supposed to comfort us on this whole
thing like we see stories that Kevin
Costner has a water purifying system
that could clean up the Gulf of Mexico
and apparently he got this idea when he
was pissing in the bottle at the
beginning of Waterworld that's no
[ __ ] one more contribution that
Waterworld has given us which comes to a
grand total of one contribution and now
we find out that James Cameron was
invited in on a brainstorming session
among the scientists who are charged
with cleaning up this oil spill problem
and I have a tiny question like
something along the lines of what the
[ __ ] does James Cameron know about
stopping an oil leak and fixing an oil
spill I mean do you think that decision
went down something like this we need a
solution and we need it fast get James
Cameron on the phone well sir that might
not be the best idea I mean what does he
really actually know about you know
oil spills the man is the director of
the abyss have you seen the abyss I have
still don't know the logic behind it
something tells me he knows the
mysteries of the deep he's a science
fiction director emphasis on the fiction
well luckily you're not in charge there
read time man it makes perfect sense
because if I'm gonna have someone save
the world let it be the man who directed
piranhas to Georgia and some people will
be like well he does spend a lot of time
in the water yeah and this bastard
spends a lot of time in women it does
not mean he understands them so
Costner's Brita filter James Cameron sit
in session and a YouTube banner pleading
for ideas all leads me to believe that
no one knows what to do anymore I mean I
think it's interesting that we've
overshot the mark for greatness we have
split the atom we have Network to the
world together we have cloned living
animals and we have artificially created
biological life but when it comes to
stopping an oil leak so I'm not even
gonna ask you guys what you guys would
do about it cuz [ __ ] I have no idea what
I'd do about it rub the magic lamp pray
but if you guys want to give a
harebrained idea that's less harebrained
than Costner's big greta filter feel
free until next time